[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm frances
foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our terrific guest today is the
co-founder of extinction rebellion
roger hall and welcome to trigonometry
hi thanks very much
for having me on no thank you for coming
on we really appreciate it just as we
were discussing before we started the
show it's great to hear
uh from people on all sides of the
various discussions that we have
in our society before we get into the
nitty-gritty
uh tell everybody who are you how are
you where you are
what has been the journey that leads you
to sitting here talking to us
well i i've always been interested in
politics and the environment i got
involved in
organizing people when i was about 14 15
people
i've been in this this game as you might
say for a long time
um in my twenties i was very much
involved in community
development work with uh housing
cooperatives and workers cooperatives
and then i was an organic farmer in
wales for 20 years
i still technically am and during
that time i became increasingly aware
of the climate crisis not least because
it was affecting
my business and the business of other
farmers and that
led me to do research
on mobilization and
civil disobedience at king's college in
london
where i'm still at doing phd research
and through that research i helped to
design and do strategic work for
extinction rebellion
which is as you can imagine taking over
my life somewhat
since it exploded into the world
in 2019
and look as as we talked about again
before the interview neither francis or
i a climate scientist or frankly
scientist of any kind
i'm pretty sure you know uh but uh
what we did want to is to pose questions
to you that a lot of ordinary people
might have
people who who are very interested in
this issue people who are very concerned
and equally people who are somewhat
skeptical so uh tell us first of all
why extinction rebellion exists and i
know that you don't speak on behalf of
it you're just
one of the people involved in it but why
was it founded
and what is the climate crisis as you
put it
yes well as you say i'm i'm just coming
on on this as
an individual in extinction rebellion i
do a lot of the
spokesworks as it were for the
organization but
in this uh video today i'm just speaking
for myself
lots of people i agree with me or may
not but i just want to make that clear
um as far as extinction rebellion is
concerned
i think really it came about
because a critical mass of people
at the same time started to realize
that the climate crisis was not just
another issue out there that it was
fundamentally
a threat to all our values on the very
basis of our society
and that realization wasn't rooted in a
particular ideology or a particular
politics
but in what you might call the
geophysics that
the weather systems around the world are
being destroyed because
carbon is being put into the atmosphere
and that's
a straightforward fact of science as you
might say
and then so much as that's happening
then
that's going to threaten all our values
and all we believe in and i think we
came along
at a time when many people were thinking
well why isn't anything happening you
know
people have been talking about this for
30 years
and the idea was the politicians and the
diplomats
were going to sort this out that had
numerous conferences
and the the horrifying statistic i
suppose is that since 1990 when
scientists around the world officially
said if we don't
sort this out we're heading for
catastrophe
carbon emissions have increased globally
by 60 percent
so there's been an you know undeniable
abject
failure by the powers that be to sort
out something that
in principle everyone wants sorting out
and it also coincided with
i don't know if you remember this was an
ipc
report this is the main organization in
the united nations
that tells the world what the state of
play is on the climate
and in october 2018 coincidentally they
came out
with this mind-blowing report which said
we have 10 to 12 years
to reduce carbon emissions by
50 in order to have
a 50 chance of remaining
under 1.5 degrees which sounds all very
technical but
what what i'm here to try and
communicate i suppose and what i think
a lot of people don't understand is 1.5
degrees
is the threshold of catastrophe
and i can speak a bit more about what
that concretely means
and that's that's really what
the has created
this massive movement around the world
along with fridays for the future and um
you know numerous other sort of
mobilizations
but what i want to try and emphasize
here is
is and this is what i want to talk about
if it's okay with you
is this idea that the climate crisis
traditionally
has been very much a fringe issue it's
been you know what the
what the diplomatic elites talk about
it's what
left-wing people talk about it for once
of a better word
and what extinction rebellion was trying
to do in my view
was to bring it into the mainstream
consciousness
of ordinary people as something that is
important for everyone
and that's why we have this slogan of
beyond politics
it's not that we don't we're not
political i mean i'm broadly left-wing
as you can imagine
what have you but that's not why i'm
involved in extinction rebellion
and the reason why lots of people are
involved in extinction rebellion
isn't because of tribal politics it's
because of a realization that if we
don't come together
we're in danger of betraying the next
generation
to an unbelievable amount of suffering
and roger you've used uh words up you've
betrayed the next generation
climate catastrophe all of this what
does that actually mean
good question one of the biggest
problems
with climate change or the climate
crisis or whatever you want to call it
is these phrases have been around for a
long time
and psychologically what happens is if
you associate something with a phrase
like climate change it tends to stick
so because climate change has been
talked about you know in the
in the 1990s and the early 2000s at that
period
quite rightly climate change was seen as
an issue
an environmental concern something that
was being sorted out we need to
actually reduce carbon emissions there's
you know just some serious implications
maybe if it doesn't happen
but what's happened in terms of the
science and the real world does it as
you might say
is that over the last 20 years and
particularly in the last 10 years
the scientists have discovered or
reiterated
that if it's not sorted out it becomes
exponentially
more scary to the point of being
terrifying
because what we're fundamentally talking
about here
is the basis of all life on earth
and i've been trying to think of an
analogy so maybe this isn't a good one
but
here we are i'll try it out on you so if
you think of society you can think of a
society like
as a dinner table and there's you know
there's night and forks there's plates
there's the food on the table
so that's like society you know there's
politics there's culture
there's people's personal lives they're
all laid out on the table and that's
what you might call
society and what the climate is the
climate isn't
another dish you know it's not the peas
on the table
it's the table itself in other words if
you
cut off a leg of the table you know it
starts to wobble if you
cut off the two legs of the table the
whole thing shutters on the floor
and this is the fundamental point of why
the climate crisis
has to be at the forefront of our minds
because if we lose those two
you know legs of the table then that's
it
it's gone so what i need to tell you for
about a few minutes is
exactly why that is the case why we are
in the process of losing the two legs of
the table as you might say
so the first thing to say is
if you're going to describe the climate
crisis you really really need to talk
about
numbers you know there's no point me
saying well it's really serious people
say it's really serious all the time but
we need to know precisely how why it's
serious
and a good analogy here is when you go
to the doctor you know you have a lump
in your chest
or something you go to the doctor you
don't want the doctor to say
well it looks like you might have cancer
what you want the doctor to say is to
get the
x-ray out and point to you know your
lungs or whatever
and say look death 45 you know diseased
and in 10 years time they're going to be
75 and then you're going to die
that's the level of responsibility the
doctor has is to actually give you the
probability analysis and the numbers
so anyone who comes on your show and
wants to talk about the climate has a
responsibility in my
view to actually give the numbers
and one of the things about client the
climate crisis is people think it's very
complicated
but as it's become more of an emergency
it's actually become reasonably
straightforward
and the reason for that is we're
basically talking about
scientific processes and the most basic
scientific process is when it's warm
ice melts which is not that complicated
so then the question is where is it
melting
how fast is it melting and what does
that mean
so the hard science is that the arctic
is melting because it's warm no one's
disputing that it's two three degrees
higher than it used to be
so that means it's disappearing and over
the last 30 40 years
it's disappeared by 70 percent in terms
of its volume
so this means you don't need to be a
genius to work this out
but at a certain point and the most
recent scientific papers
predict it will be totally melted in the
summer
in around 2030 2035.
now what i need to emphasize here is the
figures i'm going to give you
are accurate but they're not absolute
right in other words it's likely just as
when the
doctor says you've got six months to
live it could be four months and it
could be eight months
but you're not going to be around in two
years you can see what i mean
so it's the same like the ice could be
melted
it's definitely going to melt and it's
going to be around 2030 maybe 2035.
now why this should be terrifying of
everybody
is because when the ice has gone
then the weather systems around the
world which are already semi-chaotic
because of the climate crisis
are going to become even more chaotic
and that means
two precise things what it means is that
it's going to be a lot hotter
and when i say a lot hotter as a farmer
i can tell you
that it being generally hotter doesn't
matter
what matters is what you call the long
tail
in other words the really hot days you
know
if it's two degrees hotter who cares
well what the two degrees hotter means
is
is it's going to be 10 15 degrees hotter
maybe two or three weeks of the year now
if you're growing a crop
and it's over 20 degrees more than it
should be
for two or three weeks of the year then
you're going to lose the crop
so it doesn't matter that most of the
year it's you know it's a little bit
warmer than it was yesterday
that's not the issue it's like what
happens at the extreme
so that's the first problem and the
second problem is
that once the ice is substantially
melted in the arctic
the temperature difference between the
arctic and the equator
lessens because it's warmer in the
arctic and that difference between the
temperatures
drives the the wind patterns around the
northern hemisphere
so in other words everyone knows that
weather in britain is a bit useless in
the sense that
you know it's raining and then it's
sunny and then it's raining well what's
been happening over the last few years
is what's called winter blocking which
means that
it's rains it rains it rains and then it
doesn't rain at all
and the reason for this is that the
weather systems
are slowing down now again if you're a
farmer
it doesn't matter that it rains and then
it's sunny that's what you want
what's disastrous for food production is
when it rains for seven weeks
so like 12 years ago 12 15 years ago in
2006 i think it was it rained every day
in wales for seven weeks
and i lost 15 acres of vegetables now i
can tell you it doesn't matter how good
a farmer you are
if it rains every day for seven weeks
you're going to lose your crops there's
nothing you can do about
it while two years ago it didn't rain in
wales effectively for 12 weeks and then
i lost all my crops because it was so
dry
so hundreds of millions of farmers at
this
moment in time are literally panicking
because they don't know what the
weather's going to be like
and the upshot of this is is
there's going to be a food crisis
there's already been substantial food
crisis over the last 10 years
and this these crises are going to get
exponentially more
mysterious insomuch as we let the
temperature go
over one and a half degrees two degrees
and what that means to be blunt is
millions of people starving to death
in areas of the world where they don't
have you know advanced
social support systems and what that
means is master migration
and what that means is the end of the
global
you know the global world order as you
might say
now we can argue about whether it's
inevitable
or how inevitable it is i don't think
that's the main point here
i think the main point for an
intelligent conversation is
do we want to go there do we want to
play
russian roulette with our children's
lives and what's the morality of that
and what just to finish off on this what
i mean i can give you a few more facts
and figures during the conversation but
but i think the fundamental point here
is that we're in danger
in fact we're in the middle of betraying
all human values
if we betray our children because
whether you're on the right or the left
everyone agrees the most shitty thing
you can do
is send your children into an ecological
health no one wants to do that
so what we need to do as a society is to
have an intelligent conversation
about what that responsibility means and
what we need to do
in order to minimize the probability of
this horrendous thing happening
well before we get into the responsible
conversation let's have
a little bit more of the irresponsible
conversation uh just from the angle of
the sort of
skepticisms that people do have and i'm
just talking about ordinary people
who like us aren't scientists or
whatever i mean and and
the reason i bring this up is i remember
when i was in school in the 90s
and the early 90s when i left school the
official consensus was that by i think
2020 would run out of oil very soon
after we'd run out of coal
pluto was still considered a planet so
this idea that science is this great
predictor of things to come
often fails to take into account
technological progress we now extract
oil that wasn't accessible to us before
the same with coal
and on and on we go so uh how
reliable are these predictions is i
guess what i'm getting at because
isn't it possible that some elon musk
like character will come along and just
come up with some solution of either
allowing you to grow crops
in a different climate or allowing you
to cool the temperature or allowing you
to capture carbon or whatever else it
might be
isn't isn't this prediction based on
current knowledge which is never
accurate
well as i said prediction by definition
is never absolute
right so that's the first thing to say
and the second thing to say
is when you're dealing with
a horrendous risk you have to engage
with the
proportionary principle you know that's
how we need to frame the debate
we don't want to frame the debate that
because we can't prove it
then you know it doesn't matter so
a good analogy here is is would you put
your children
onto an aeroplane if there was a five
percent chance of it crushing
well not unless you're a psychopath or
you don't like them
you wouldn't put your children onto a
plane if there was a possibility
of you know a 20 chance but we don't
really know but it could be a one
percent chance
you still wouldn't risk it roger but
hold on this is a bit of an
unfair argument in my view because at
least my understanding of extinction
rebellion
and other people who talk about the
climate is you're asking for very very
drastic changes to
people's ways of life you're asking
people to massively reduce
their consumption you're asking for
societies to be restructured all of that
sort of stuff
right so it's not a choice between
putting your kids on a plane and not
putting them on a plane it's
it's a choice between putting them on
one plane which has a one percent chance
of killing them or putting on this other
plane which has a hundred percent chance
of ruining their life that's how some
people
let me give you three clear
scientific situations right number one
at the moment we're at 1.3 degrees above
pre-industrial temperatures
the hottest or the double hottest year
with 2016.
and temperatures have gone up on average
by 0.3 degrees of a centigrade between
2010 and 2020.
between 2000 and 2010 it was 0.2
so there's a broad exponential increase
broadly speaking
okay so if you do the simple maths on
this we're at 1.3 at the moment in 2020
we need to add on 0.3 to get
what we're predicted to be at by 2030.
so 1.3 plus 0.3 is 1.6
now what we've been told for the last
you know five years
is there's a paris agreement and we're
going to keep the temperatures at 1.5
so the first thing to establish is we're
already
effectively locked in 1.5 degrees and
many scientists
and i talked to many of the top
scientists in the world are adamant that
we're heading over two degrees
so that's the first data point right a
second data point
is is what does this actually mean what
it means
is that it's going to be increasingly
difficult to live
in the tropical areas of the world so
one
one scientific paper has said that at
two degrees centigrade
a thousand million people are going to
be forced to move
a thousand million people at two degrees
centigrade
in other words like many of the areas in
africa
in the central america in india are
going to run out of water
they're going to have extreme weather
events and we're going to have
massive migration now what we
what we know is that migration
without talking about the politics of it
but we know sociologically that
migration is a massively disruptive
event
both for the people that are migrating
obviously and also for the countries
that receive that migration i think we
received what
five million people something like that
in europe from from
syria now the reason the syrian civil
war happened
arguably was because that there was a
massive drought which was related to
climate change
so that was a little canary in the coal
mine as you might say
so that gives you a taste of what's
coming down the line
if you start moving towards two degrees
centigrade
and another another um data point is
what's happening
in green in greenland so it's an
established factor no one disputes this
so if the greenland ice cap melts it
will increase
um sea levels by seven meters
that's seven meters on average right
and everyone agrees that if the temp if
the sea levels rise
above two to three meters you'll have to
evacuate all the coastal cities of the
world
short of those that are rich enough to
build great big walls
in other words that is a catastrophe
on lots of different levels humanly
economically
socially and this is the this is the
situation
is the scientific papers come out this
year that say we are
already we are already locked in the
melting
of the green and ice sheet so what's
been happening over the last 10
20 years is we've handed over to future
generations
a massive increase in in sea level rise
and this will only get worse there's a
lot of dispute around whether it's
locked in
on west antarctica that's another five
meters of sea level rise
this this gives a taste you know i mean
i've talked for half an hour
but what i'm trying to communicate is is
on multiple levels we're reaching the
point of no return
and we're reaching the point of a
non-linear catastrophe
so roger that being the case why is it
the governments around the world haven't
done more
if this is the case if we really are on
the edge
of a complete total climactic
catastrophe
well there's a number of different ideas
on this
what what i want to establish is the
science is not political
what i've just said is not political you
know it's it's
it's the geophysics it's the biology and
i just want to add in if you don't mind
i forgot yes amazon right let's just
throw in the amazon and then we're done
the amazon has has been reduced in size
by 17
right over the last 30 years so it's
it's 17
less than it used to be now what the
scientists are saying
is if you cut down more of the amazon
between 20 and 25
then it the ecology of the amazon goes
into a natural die back
in other words because the amazon exists
because
of the rainfall and the rainfall exists
because the amazon
evaporates water now if you remove those
if you remove a certain proportion of
the amazon
that feedback mechanism doesn't work
anymore and the whole thing
dies of its own accord in the same way
as what's happening in the arctic with
the temperature
and if you lose the amazon if you lose
it all turns to desert and
savannah then you've got a massive
amount of carbon that isn't being taken
out of the atmosphere
so it's a bit like kicking a ball down a
hill
at a certain point you run after it but
it's going faster and faster you don't
catch it
so that's the terrifying geophysical
reality
because all these things are
interconnected roger but come back to
france's point which is
you say do you say the science isn't
political yeah
if it isn't political why isn't why
aren't governments doing more about it
well my answer to why governments aren't
doing anything about it is a lot more
disputable
because it's a subject right you know
i mean everyone's got their own theory i
mean i'm a sociologist
so i can give you some reasons which i
hope are reasonably
objective as you might say but they're
disputable okay
but i think there's two main reasons in
the literature as you might say
on what what is holding governments back
so the first
the first problem is the collective
action problem which is the technical
word for
i'm not going to do it because no one
else is you know
and we all know this from our personal
lives or you know clearing up the litter
in the street you know everyone wants
their litter to be cleared up but no
one's doing it because why should i do
it
and and you can see this happening over
and over again
with competing nation states you've just
described the cleaning schedule at the
trigonometry studio
exactly exactly the famous washing up
situation in student health you know
everyone knows it don't they
so what's been happening for 30 years
is people don't want to engage in what
are now
substantial costs let's not beat around
the bush
the substantial cost in reducing carbon
in the time we've got
in order to not you know minimize this
substantial risk
and the other reason which is
potentially more controversial but i
think it's
it's the substantial evidence for it
which is that the
the the world economy is controlled
by the corporate companies and the
corporate companies
are dedicated to maintaining profit
maximization
and profit maximization depends upon the
fossil fuel economy
and they have very powerful lobbying
mechanisms
and over the last 30 years a little bit
like what happened with tobacco
in the 1970s and 1980s they have very
powerful pr machines
to to create confusion on what the
substantial risks are
and that's a massive problem because if
people think
you know like you could say well if it's
if it's not really certain then
why don't we just carry on flying to
spain you know it's
it creates that that confusion and
that's a disaster of course as it was a
disaster in terms of
convincing the public about the dangers
of lung cancer
with tobacco so those are the two things
that we seem to be up against
and i think one of the ways of combating
this as you might say
is to communicate to the general public
that it's in everyone's interest
as a parent as a citizen as a human
being
to engage with this and pressurize
governments
to counteract the special interests in
society
that want to make money out of you know
keeping the system in the same way as it
has been
hey kkk do you like feeling silky and
smooth
like a sexual dolphin never talk to me
again
what if i told you that manscaped have
brought out a new
and improved lawnmower 3.0 that allows
you to be fresh
and trim for the ladies down below
i've been married 20 years the last time
i was fresh and trimmed down below
jimmy savile was a respected children's
entertainer i'm going to ignore that
the lawnmower has a cutting-edge ceramic
blade which reduces a risk of having an
accident
where you least want an accident my bank
account no you idiot you know
los huevos oh right plus it's waterproof
which means you can groom in the shower
and it has an led light
so you can get a really accurate and
precise trim
x to take advantage of this incredible
offer go to manscape.com
and you'll get 20 off with free shipping
just use our code which is of course
trigger that's 20 off with free shipping
at
manscape.com and use our code trigger
your werewolfs well thank you excellent
but isn't the problem roger going to be
persuading governments but
especially persuading third world
nations that in order to do this they
have to act against their own financial
self-interest
that is surely a non-argument isn't it
it's very difficult i'm not going to
pretend it
we're not in a complete mess right you
know
if as a social scientist i would say
that the situation is
is awful one because we're facing this
a terrible threat and also because the
human race
is not very good at looking after its
long-term interests
so yes i agree with you but i think what
we need to consider here
is not you know something doesn't work
but more like what is the most effective
way of dealing with it relative to other
options
so it's not acceptable in terms of an
argument to say
well roger that doesn't sound like it's
going to work
you have a responsibility to say what
will work
other than sitting on your city on
social media just being cynical because
what we do know is just sitting on your
city doing nothing
guarantees catastrophe you see what i
mean so
what i'm here to suggest i suppose is
it's a long shot but the long shot the
most effective
way of bringing about political change
and let's not forget there's been plenty
of radical political change in the past
so it's not impossible but in so much as
it is possible
it requires people to step up into their
responsibilities
as parents as members of their community
as citizens and say to governments this
is an
unacceptable level of risk regardless of
our culture our backgrounds
our politics everyone agrees unless
you're on the
extreme of the political spectrum or
nearly still you know mad
everyone agrees we don't want to have
this catastrophe
locked in because what we need to
understand here
is that once this goes it's almost
impossible to bring it back
roger you talk about responsibility so
we are
all three of us sitting here in the
united kingdom uh there'll be people
watching this all over the western world
primarily
what percentage of global emissions is
the uk currently responsible for
it's around two percent right so so hold
on
let me pose a question i know that you
know where i'm going but just so that
our viewers
get to hear me say so if if we are
responsible for two percent of global
emissions
surely with countries like china and
india which are only doing the best
francis says the best for their citizens
trying to catch up on the economic race
trying to prevent their children from
starving to death from malnutrition and
so on
those countries being responsible for a
huge percentage of the
of the world's uh emissions how how does
shutting down our level of well-being
and consumption and whatever
really help anything that's a question
that i think a reasonable question a lot
of people will be asking isn't it
yeah well there's several things to say
about this the first thing to say is how
you account for the two percent
you know what there's a little slight of
hand as it were statistically or a large
slide abandoned it goes like this
in the 1980s and 1990s a lot of
the production of what we consume in
this country
was was based in britain and so the
carbon emissions
from those industries was part of our
account as you might say
now as we all know over the last 30
years britain's largely
de-industrialized and a large proportion
of what we consume in this country is
produced in china
and various other countries so it's a
little bit of a problem to say well
we're just sitting here
only producing two percent of emissions
do you have an estimate for
for what it should be no i can give you
an interesting figure which is
a recent estimate is the city of london
our financing produces
the financing that happens in the city
of london is around 15 percent of
emissions
which is a slightly different point
because you know
britain does three things it can it
produces emissions
it consumes emissions and it finances
emissions
so we have to look at all those things i
don't have the figure
on what we produce but obviously it's
not going to be
i don't have a figure on what um what
the
carbon emissions are of everything we
produce but i accept it's not an
enormous percentage
which brings us back to the collective
action problem which is i know where
you're what you're getting it's been
like
why should we reduce emissions if no one
else's well
because we're on the pathway to hell if
we don't
no but with respect it isn't it isn't
that that
simple it's not why should we do
anything if no one else is it's more
like
why should we do anything when what we
do makes no impact
okay so what
happens when people when a country makes
a start on something
they often though not necessarily but it
often
triggers other countries doing the same
so you saw this a little bit with the
you know denuclearization of nuclear
weapons and that's
that area so what happens is one country
decides to
make a move and then it encourages other
countries
now that is not guaranteed but the point
here is
if everyone sits in their corner
and says well i'm not going to move
unless other people do
then we know what happens right it's
well established in game theory what
have you
is everyone loses and again everyone
loses big time and potentially forever
so we can't underestimate the situation
there's another issue though
on the moral level that needs to be
considered here well two
one is is historically the global north
has been responsible for 90 of those
emissions
it's only in the last 10 years that
china has come up
you know producing many of the goods of
course for the western world to consume
so it's a little bit problematic morally
for us to say well
you know we produced this problem and
now we don't want to bear any
responsibility for it
and the other thing is still
substantially speaking
most of the world's emissions are
produced and consumed in the global
north
so it's still really a matter of western
europe north america
and china coming together and making
this happen
and any pressure that citizens can
produce on their governments is going to
help this process move along that's the
bottom line it's a great answer roger
and it's a very very good point as well
because like with anything like you said
game three somebody needs to make the
most
first move somebody needs to make the
stand and so on and so forth i want to
move the question on
the interview along now to extinction
rebellion now extinction rebellion very
very much hit the headlines in 2019
particularly
um what is extinction rebellion because
i've looked at it and you know there's
lots of contrasting ideas here
you know it doesn't seem to be a
centralized organization
so could you explain to us and everybody
else what is extinction rebellion
and what are its goals
okay well extinction rebellion is a
civil disobedience organization it
exists
to create civil disobedience so i need
to explain civilis disobedience a little
bit
civil disputes is often misunderstood as
you know unpleasant people causing
disruption for no good reason
okay and what i need to
you know get to get to the heart of the
matter what
civil disobedience does is it challenges
society to engage morally with an issue
when there's a substantial violation of
society's morals
that's when it where it primarily works
and we all know
the example of martin luther king in in
the american south with the
racism in the 1960s and what the
the martin luther king's organization
decided to do
after 70 years of asking for their
rights was hang on a minute
you know we can't wait any longer people
need their rights
and they engage in civil disobedience
sitting in the road
and such like getting arrested going to
prison
and what that did was it produced the
headlines
it produced a national debate on what it
meant to be american
what it meant to have equal rights and
over seven or eight years
the attitudes in america change from you
know
those blacks down in the south you know
whatever through to
know this is an absolutely important
issue and our self-respect individually
as a nation is at stake and racism is
intolerable
so what extinction rebellion is is set
up to do
is to produce a similar process on
climate change
which is climate change is no longer
just a little issue a little bit like
what it was in america in terms of black
rights it's not a peripheral issue
it's central to our conception of
moral self-respect as a society
we we're in a society where our
fundamental value is
we respect human life we respect our
children
we respect giving people you know
not [ __ ] on people for no good
reason
roger if i could just push back on you
just ever so slightly there so
i'm really glad we talked about the
civil disobedience thing i remember an
incident i think it was in 2019
where there was an extinction rebellion
protester who got on top of a dlr train
at canning town
and i used to be a teacher around there
and
the fury that was unleashed at that
what seemed to me in particular to
somebody who had worked in that area for
many many years
was that it was a type of deafness
to the people who lived and worked in
that
particular community who were primarily
working class
the moment you start interfering with
their way of getting into work
that means they're not going to get paid
because a lot of them are zero hours
contract
so doesn't this type of political
disobedience
alienate the very people that you're
trying to win over
the fact of the matter is when people
engage in civil disobedience
they end up upsetting a lot of people
and the reason that is because a lot of
people
quite understandably don't want to deal
with
the cognitive dissonance of believing
one thing and something else happening
and and there's a process there's a
well-established process
which is people hate them when they
start off
and then they start thinking well i
still think that what they're doing is
terrible but i have to accept they have
a point
and then they go through to the process
of going actually
you know these guys are right you know
we're we're transgressing our basic
values here
now that's not a smooth process we're
living in the real world here
and in every civil disobedience campaign
there's going to be off moments and you
know difficulties
and things which aren't tactically
appropriate as you might say
but the substantial point here is
there's no way
of changing society in a fundamental way
without upsetting people but the the key
point here and this is
often misunderstood about civil disputes
civil disobedience isn't a process of
shutting down debate
and this is one of the reasons i wanted
to come on today was
is to make this argument that civil
justice when it's done well right you
know
we all know things can be done well and
done badly but when it's done well
what civil disputence is about is not
just disruption
it is disruption because the disruption
is required to get attention
but once you've got that attention the
idea
is there's a whole other side to the
equation which is dialogue
you sit down with your opponent and you
engage in respectful communication
in order to find a resolution so
what i want to communicate is this is at
the heart
of our democratic culture which is
you disagree with people you talk to
them and through talking you come to
up to some common ground now the reason
the civil disobedience is necessary and
obviously
a lot of the time it's not you know a
lot of the time you can sit down and
resolve things
but sometimes in society and in history
as we all know
there's entrenched power is injustice
and it's right as we all agree with the
suffragettes or
the civil rights movements or the early
trade unions it was right for them
to engage in civil disputes if it was
properly done
and engage in this dialogue and that's
one of the reasons
i go around you know talking to people
about this because the communication is
vital
in order for us to come together
otherwise you spiral into this
you know over polarization of the phrase
goes
and that you know leads to all the
problems that we see in
in society in many ways at the moment
not least in america of course
uh roger you almost given me goosebumps
here the idea that people
from different sides can talk rationally
and discuss things
and and have these conversations uh uh
you mentioned
earlier when we were talking about the
climate issue directly
that you feel that a large reason for
government in action
is that uh they're heavily influenced by
corporate lobbyists and so on
do you think that uh if that is true
uh there will be a lot of interference
with what
extinction rebellion is doing from those
sorts of
organizations because if big tech
companies don't want this to happen if
big corporations don't want this to
happen
well as we've seen recently they have
the power to
take people off their platform they have
the power to stop people from
communicating from organizing from
from doing all sorts of things so are
you concerned about
uh the the interference of big
corporations into our politics into the
sort of discussions that even we're
having here today
well it goes without saying that when
societies engage in terrible activities
then it's very difficult to change them
and it's going to be a battle
and our history is full of battles for
justice for rights
and if you look at that history it's not
a straight line
it's very difficult and often they fail
and then they come back and
maybe they you know become corrupt and
they collapse and then they come back
it's not a straight line thing but what
we know
is two things right number one is the
powers that be
never give up power without a fight
that's just the way it is
and secondly if you mobilize enough
people power
it's possible it's never it's never
inevitable of course
but it's it's possible and it's happened
many times that you can win
and there's a good quote from gandhi on
this who obviously knew a thing or two
about you know changing things not least
with regards to the british empire
but he said first of all they ignore you
then they laugh at you then they fight
you and then you win
so what those of us that are involved in
civil disobedience globally have that
on our wall because what we know is when
the corporations
and people that have special interests
in maintaining carbon emissions
tell lies about us and try and turn
people up off offers
we know we're getting somewhere because
we're ruffling the feathers
and the name of the game of course is to
persist
in our activities until we start winning
and that's really the strategy of
extinction rebellion
do you watch problematic content online
of course they do they watch
trigonometry
many isps log your internet activity
and sell that data on to other big tech
companies
or other advertising companies i know
that is why
i use expressvpn to hide my browsing
activities
i bet you do expressvpn is a simple app
that you can have on both your computer
and your smartphone which hides your
traffic into one channel
and directs it through a vpn server
which means your isp can't see anything
that you're doing
look the question i want to ask no will
it slow down the videos that i watch
definitely not that is one of the
reasons it's been rated as the number
one
vpn app by cnet and wyatt i don't read
those publications because i'm not a
nerd
stop handing over your personal data to
isps and big tech companies which are
just gonna use it and sell it on visit
expressvpn.com trigger
that's e x p r e
s s v p n dot
com slash trigger i love it when you
spell things out but it gets even better
than that
expressvpn are offering trigonometry
fans three
extra months free go to expressvpn.com
trigger to learn more
and what would you say to those people
roger you go look the planet is warming
up that's indisputable
but it's not man-made this is just part
of what the planet does it goes through
ice age
then it goes through warmer it goes
through warmer periods
and what you're essentially trying to do
is trying to stop a natural phenomenon
yeah well i think with all due respect
that's one of those sort of flat earth
theories at this stage of the game
and obviously lots of people various
psychological reasons might want to
believe that the earth is flat and so
dear but in some
democratic debates about you know basing
our discussions and what's real what the
science says
then the issue is beyond dispute at this
stage
99 of scientists around the world say
that climate change is caused by human
activities
so the debate has largely moved on in
terms of anyone that's interested in
what's actually happening
and the real issue now is how bad is it
you know at what point is is it going to
be a situation of no return
and how exactly is this tragedy going to
play out
if if we don't get our act together
roger i'm curious
what you think because i've always
thought that uh
given the situation you've described i
don't understand
and i say this as someone who's whose
wife was
essentially evacuated from the chernobyl
area so i'm aware of the risks but
i don't understand why nuclear power
isn't seen as a large part of the
solution
where where are you or extinction
rebellion on that issue
okay so it's important to understand
that extinction rebellion
is not does not exist to take over the
world
right it's real it's a relatively humble
proposition
just canning town
that was only for two hours
[Laughter]
okay so um you know everyone does
something wrong for at least two hours
in their life let's put it like that
the point well the point of extinction
rebellion
is that we see ourselves in the heart of
what you might call the
the the open democratic tradition in the
western world
and what that concretely means is we
engage in respectful civil disputes and
i've described
why and how that works but also we don't
engage in some
sort of leninist project but we're so
important
that we can tell the british public how
they're going to respond
to the climate crisis that's not our job
it's the job for the democratic process
our job is to say to society and say to
the government
we have to massively reduce carbon
emissions because that's what the
science dictates
that's not an issue of politics it's an
issue of morality
and basic common sense now how we do it
is not our job because we're not experts
in nuclear power
we're not experts in in knowing the
collective minds of the british public
maybe the british public wants to
support nuclear power maybe he wants to
you know do renewable energy so i've got
my own personal views on it but i don't
think
that's what i'm here to say what i'm
here to say
is that what extinction rebellion is
suggesting
is that what i think is a genius
solution
to the the very
emotional debate that we need to have
around what needs to be done because
it's not going to be easy everyone knows
it's not going to be easy
it's a big decision to be made and that
solution is the citizens assembly
and what a citizen assembly is that has
a technical definition
which is you select people randomly from
the country
to sit in an assembly and a little bit
like a court
people provide concrete empirical
evidence
on what the situation is and what the
options are
and then those ordinary people in the
country as representatives that you
might say of the commonwealth of the
country
decide what should be done and how it
should be done
so in other words like if for the sake
of argument sixty percent of the british
public or working class will be sixty
percent
in the assembly if twenty percent of the
british probably occur people of color
then there'll be twenty percent
if thirty percent could come from the
north of england will be 30
if one percent of the population is
super rich they don't get to say what
happens there's only one percent of
those in the assembly
so it's profoundly democratic but in
terms
of you know the things you've been
talking about in your videos
what i think is interesting here is the
process of deliberation which is when
you bring people together
and this has been apparently shown by
the research if you put people in the
room
and you give them several hours to
communicate where they're at
you humanize the relationship people
aren't looking at something on twitter
they're not you know just having a
knee-jerk reaction something they're
reading the tabloid
they're talking to real human beings eye
to eye contact
and within half an hour and i've
personally done research on this
within half an hour an hour people are
all you know best of mates
you know because no one likes to be a an
idiot right in front of someone else
people naturally want to agree with each
other when
when they're sitting down assuming you
know they're reasonable people
which most people are and what that
produces
is a sense of common purpose that we're
all here we've all got our differences
but we're all human beings we're all
british we're all part of
a similar national community or whatever
and through that process you come
up with a consensus and what that does
is is reduces the polarization in the
country
between those that say no we don't want
to do this we do want to do that
because once you've seen like a bus
driver from birmingham as you might say
come out on the steps of thousands of
parliament and say
you know these 300 people from around
the country have considered climate
change
and this is what we think happened then
everyone's going to go well most people
are going to go
fair enough mate you know if he said
that and he's a normal person he's not
one of those men in suits
then you can see how this can help to
heal
you know divisions and what we're
heading for is the
mother of all divisions on the climate
crisis because every month and year that
goes by
the more difficult you know the
decisions are going to be
have to be made and you know this has a
implication really more generally for
the polarization that we see in our
society today and roger do you think
this is about what you're going to win
because you're up against some pretty
big opponents let's be fair you've
already just said you know these huge
multinational corporations they've got
billions and billions of
dollars and all the rest of it and the
best lawyers in the world backing them
yes well i the answer to that is yes
i think we will win and the reason for
that
is because it's over there's
overwhelming evidence now
that this is a terrible terrible threat
that violates all human values
and violates everyone's life whether
they're rich or poor or wherever they
live in the world
but the caveat is whether we make that
decision in time
right that's the really scary thing here
that this is the important thing to
understand
we're not dealing with a social issue
here we're not dealing with
you know slave real human rights or
trade union rights
where if you don't sort them out this
year they're going to be
you know just as bad next year but not
lots worse
what we're dealing with with here is a
geophysical
situation we're dealing with a meteorite
coming towards the earth you understand
what i'm saying
in other words if you don't deal with it
that today it's going to be 10 times
worse tomorrow
and if you don't deal with it tomorrow
it's going to be 100 in other words
we've got no time
and that's not an ideological you know
pressurizing statement
it's it's the physics of it in the same
way as you go to a doctor and you say
look
if you don't deal with this cancer you
go too late you're dead right
that's how nature works that's how
physics works so that's the really
important thing to communicate to people
and
the last thing i want to say is you know
for myself and for many people involved
in extinction rebellion
and for many people i think in the
country as well
the issue really isn't at the end of the
day will we win won't we win
it's more an issue of i have respect for
myself
as a citizen as an upright person and i
don't want to be
you know on my deathbed going well i
knew about the climate crisis but i just
sat
on social media you know being cynical
about it and doing nothing
i felt whatever happens i need to step
up and make a stand
and in our history that's really the
reason why many people get involved in
trying to improve society is because
they
they they want to feel the self-respect
of being a citizen
being a parent and all the rest of it
and that's you know that's my
invitation i suppose to people listening
to this and maybe to the two of you
yeah you can come down to extinction
rebellion and interview people right
i'd love francis to be at the forefront
of that effort yeah
but roger thank you so much it's been a
wonderful and genuinely insightful
interview we always finish our
interviews with the same question which
is constantine what's the one thing
we're not talking about as a society
other than climate change
that we really should be
well i think what i've been trying to
elude to as you might say in this in
this conversation
is there's a broader issue here which i
know you guys have been talking about
which is how we can create a society
where people
can have differences but not dismiss
people and try and counsel each other
and try and destroy each other
and that's a 5 000 year debate that i
think you probably know
so probably we're not going to totally
sort it out
but what i would like to suggest i
suppose
is what extinction rebellion is pointing
towards is several mechanisms
through which we can create that that
more healthy society through respectful
civil disobedience where things are
definitely going up the rails
and also through systems assemblies
where people
sit down and have dialogues with each
other
and quickly realize we're all human
right
we all make mistakes we all do cunning
streets
you know we're all we're all in the same
boat
and we're all going to be dead soon so
you know we've only got one live
so let's get things in perspective and
work together
and that's the most enjoyable way to
live anyway isn't it
as far as i'm aware it is it is roger
and uh we really genuinely thank you
uh for coming on the show and for
talking about all of this i think uh
you know frankly whether people agree
with you and everything and disagree
with the internet i think everybody
would have to recognize that
history has been made by people like you
whether whether they like that fact or
not
that is reality people who have strong
convictions believe in what in in
in something whatever that is uh and and
try and
um encourage others to do the same and
in my view
whatever people's political views or
views on this issue
as long as everybody is coming at it
from a place of trying to have a
discussion having a civil
conversation yes you can do a little bit
of civil disobedience and disruption as
well if you feel that strongly about it
i think that's all for the best frankly
uh irrespective
of of what those people are actually
saying frankly so the methods
i i think are perfectly legitimate and i
i'm really pleased to have had you on
the show for people to see
where you're coming from absolutely
roger and if people want to follow you
on social media i know that we've been
trashing it for the last hour or so
or if they want to get involved in uh
your cause what is the best way to do
that
yes if you look of extinction rebellion
on social media it'll point you in all
the different social media channels
and yeah there's 400 groups around the
uk
i think there's 700 groups around the
world so yes get involved and
come and do your bit thank you very much
thanks roger and thank you for watching
we will see you very soon with another
interview
or a live stream all of them at 7 pm uk
time
take care and see you soon guys we hope
you've enjoyed this
incredible interview remember to
subscribe and hit the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below